the gulch tall bridge near net cow is
the folk lands most famous landmark it's
the world's largest bridge made out of
brick and serves as the northern gate to
the region this is where our tour begins
we take the panorama route that runs
right under the bridge from net cow
towards plowin
it follows the former inner german
border today it forms part of a nature
reserve
few signs of a once divided Germany
remain
after 20 kilometers we reach the town of
plowin for centuries plowin has been
known for its world-famous lace the
center of Germany's lace-making trade
there are still more than 40 specialist
firms operating here to this day at this
museum visitors can see firsthand how
lace used to be made with its modern
technology and production methods plowin
became an international leader in lace
manufacturing in the early 20th century
leaving the competition behind da
mcgowan became world leader putting an
end to the Swiss monopoly creations by
contemporary plow and designers give
visitors insight into the latest
developments in lace making and
demonstrate the technological
innovations within the industry
plauen didn't just produce for the world
market for a short time it also made
world history this monument commemorates
the events of 1989 on october 7th some
fifteen thousand protesters staged the
first large-scale demonstration against
the East German regime here in plowin
that was weeks before the famous
demonstrations took place in life see
physician Frank goonette was a member of
the opposition movement neues forum he
attended the demonstration in 1989 and
campaign for the construction of the
monument yup flannels and stoats thought
of this to see the people of plowin are
proud that the first large-scale
demonstration in East Germany wasn't
broken up by armed authorities when we
always say that the massive
demonstrations that took place in
Leipzig two weeks later and spelled the
end of the dictatorship that they might
not have taken the course they did
without plowing do for love the era is
useful of Miss we continue our scenic
journey heading towards the town of mock
no occasion
musical instruments have been built here
for some 350 years before the Second
World War 75% of orchestral instruments
worldwide came from marked no occasion
and the surrounding region some 100
firms still operate here and clients
come from all over the world
you
who doke watchman has been making
violins for 40 years music abuddin have
two musicians mostly want the Italian
sound it's the dream of every musician
by but it's hard to put into words it's
a fascinating detail the old Italian
sound has to be a warm soft sound that
carries well and the violin makers here
in mock noi Kish and try to reproduce
this sound easy but only the musicians
can judge whether or not we succeed in
divide the skilling dismissing too deep
would you go for it appears that they
have been succeeding and for generations
as a trip to the local instrument museum
demonstrates
some 5000 instruments are on display
here
from mocno occasion and the whole world
and from the 17th century to the present
day if you're lucky you might get to
hear a pianola from the early 20th
century
you
that's how easy it was to play the piano
one last stretch along the panorama
route to our last destination Klingon
top with its scenic views the town is
also home to instrument builders but the
focus here is on Heights for more than a
hundred years client all has been a
favorite destination for winter sports
enthusiasts today it's a mecca for ski
jumping fans you can see why at the folk
land arena here visitors are taken 137
meters up the slope you need a good head
for Heights and once at the top visitors
are treated to the breathtaking view
that awaits prospective ski jumpers just
imagine them jumping from here he
normally only see it on TV I didn't
think it was this high watched unzips
religious
from this vantage point visitors looking
out beyond the slope can take an almost
the entire folk laundry j'en